lance donc aujourd'hui son semaine pour
la démocratie le président américain a
convié virtuellement une centaine de
pays qui participent
aux États-Unis et
[Musique]
notre correspondant
Washington organise pour la première
fois un sommet pour les démocraties en
événement virtuel avec 111 pays qui ont
été invité par jour Bible dans
l'événement qui va se dérouler dans un
climat de défiance y compris de la part
de certains pays qui ont été invité et
qui exprime quelques réserves sur les
réels intention américaine certaines
chancellerie européenne se sont
notamment ému de l'absence de la Hongrie
lors de cet événement et même certains
médias américain exprime de sérieux
doutes sur les invitation lancée par Joe
Biden à certains pays est pas d'autre et
puis il a man du côté de ceux qui n'ont
pas été congé on pointe le biais
idéologique américain et emmener à la
composition de ce sommet écouter par
exemple ce qu'on dit de sommeil pour la
démocratie du côté de Pékin
malgré la large opposition de la
communauté internationale les États-Unis
s'obstine à engager une manipulation
politique sous la bannière de la
démocratie et que jamais son intention
d'accueillir le sommet avec humilité
voici des questions auxquelles les
États-Unis de répondre les États-Unis
organise un sommeil au nom de la
démocratie sans consulter la communauté
internationale où se coordonner avec les
Nations Unies ou d'autres organisations
internationales est-ce cela qu'on
appelle l'humilité au nom de la
démocratie les États-Unis ont lancé des
interventions militaires en Afghanistan
en Irak en Syrie et dans d'autres pays
me y en a des centaines de milliers de
morts civils et au déplacement de
dizaines de millions de personnes au
lieu d'apprendre de ses erreurs les
États-Unis sont encore plus loin pour
instrumentaliser et armée la démocratie
en tenant ouvertement ce soit disant
sommet pour la démocratie pour inciter à
la division et la confrontation à des
fins de stratégie géopolitique est-ce qu
on appelle ça l'humilité
c'est vrai que ce soit mais semble
reprendre les vieux réflexes de l'époque
de la guerre froide il y aurait même de
l'embarras chez certains pays invités
selon les propos de certains médias
américain ici ces pays ne voudrais pas
être utilisé à l'heure des pendant une
guerre à distance entre Washington et
Moscou et Pékin et donc elle très
difficile de savoir ce qui pourrait
ressortir concrètement de ce sommet qui
va donc se dérouler de façon virtuelle
ce jeudi et ce vendredi avant un autre
volet qui devrait être organisé dans le
courant de l'année prochaine